- So a judge rules that the Trump campaign
non-disclosure agreement,
the NDA, is invalid.
The story behind this
particular case is incredible.
It's been going on for years but,
Jessica Denson most recently has filed
a class-action lawsuit
to invalidate the Trump campaign's NDA
that was preventing her from disclosing
what she saw and learned
as a member of the Trump campaign.
So at the moment, at least
one federal court has said
that her particular NDA
is non-enforceable but
she's filed this as a class action
and it appears that she and her lawyers
intend to move forward and
invalidate all of the NDAs
with respect to the people
that worked for the Trump campaign.
So this is not the last that we have heard
of this particular lawsuit.
It may eventually go up
to the Court of Appeals,
but for the time being,
it doesn't look good
for the Trump campaign.
So we'll see them in court.